l'été n'a pas attendu le 21 juin le
musée maurice denis
la statue sans bras d'aristide maillol
prêtés par le musée maillol annonce la
saison à venir
une arrivée qui a poussé les équipes du
musée à ouvrir son jardin pourvu de
grands arbres centenaires
ce jardin il a été aménagé par les
jésuites par une communauté de jésuites
à la fin du 19e siècle dans un terrain
qui existait déjà depuis la fin du xviie
siècle
et quand maurice denis donc le peintre a
acheté cette maison en 1914 il a fait
beaucoup de travaux à l'intérieur de la
maison pour la transformer en habitation
mais par contre il a vraiment respecté
l'esprit de ce jardin spirituelle qui
avait conçu les jésuites avec des
solitudes avec des endroits pour prier
pour les jésuites mais aujourd'hui pour
lire pour rêver laissée à l'état sauvage
depuis trois ans en raison des travaux
intérieurs
les mains vertes du département lui ont
refait une beauté l'ouverture s'inscrit
dans là 18e édition des rendez vous aux
jardins du ministère de la culture pour
ce premier rendez-vous le musée a convié
des associations autour de la
biodiversité sensibiliser le public
informé faire prendre conscience donc de
certaines pratiques néfastes et d'autres
bonnes pratiques
cette très jolie ses tresses est très
bon c'est merveilleux et jardins être
bon ac c'est super g à l'année beau mais
avec à tous les stands c'est informatif
et éducative à on a beaucoup appris sur
les composts le jardin du musée maurice
denis accueille du public les deux
prochains week-ends l'entrée est
gratuite mais les réservations sont
fortement recommandés pour les
animations au programme fabrication de
peintures naturelles compte susanna ou
encore une conférence découverte autour
de la statue d'aristide maillol